that is a spork it's a spoon and a fork
everyone's favorite utensil I think
[Music]
Christopher Columbus was packing for his
trip oh yeah he thought was India yeah
you know he had these box filled with
silverware hey we don't have enough
space for food because of all the eat
ensel's that you brought on the ship and
then out of the corner of his eye just
the way that the Sun was hitting his
sundial and then reflecting on the boxes
he saw a spoon and then a fork right
behind it and it was like the perfect
Eclipse you're going crazy hey chris hey
Chris what's a powder with oh sorry I
just invented the spork oh it's a great
two-in-one invention yeah a plus I say
I know these are these are roller skates
no well once before roller skates they
were like a Butler's mode of
transportation around the mansion
because he's like oh like all these
people what like their bread and their
Tina crumpets and like their hair done
he couldn't do the amount of work in an
efficient amount of time Butler's can't
run no they'll get fired but you also to
be quick so what are you gonna do so he
saw the invention of the car and was
like pretty good but he try to get the
car in the house and tried to do errands
with the car and it just like didn't
work then he was like oh I guess I'll
just put the car on my feet so that's
what he got shoes with wheels to form
thee the butler Richard C Davidson he
was a mayor who was like this affable
man affable man of the a handlebar
moustache and it kept curling mm-hmm
within itself he was really into
actually like basket weaving and and
that was his hobby being a mayor was his
job but basket weaving was his passion
he'd get off the day of layering where
he you know makes hard decisions about
the town mm-hmm but then he'd come home
and go I just need the compressor
compressor faster yeah he ran out of
thin wood because there was that like
the the wood board age of 1862 1862 yeah
also in 1862 was the great shoes Boone
mm-hmm factories had the cheese this is
how much 20 I was like piling up right
outside the trucks and of course they
just delivered it to the mayor's office
so what he did was like these are gonna
sound crazy but what if I weaved with
those Jews and then he we'd these like
gorgeous thin little strings and built
it into this beautiful not basket like a
rod shape because just that's the way
that the cheese spokes in that way it's
literally art you can eat
[Music]